Florida Republicans are now looking to
push the state's 15-week abortion ban to
a six-week abortion ban and a few of you
wrote to me and said David this bill
doesn't make any sense women often don't
know that they're pregnant before the
six week Mark but that is exactly why it
makes perfect sense to the people who
are trying to completely ban abortion it
is a feature of this proposal that many
women don't know they're pregnant before
the six-month Mark not a bug and we are
going to discuss that in more detail the
New York New York Times reports Florida
Republicans proposed six-week abortion
ban the bills would tighten the current
15-week limit and offer narrow
exceptions Governor Ron DeSantis said he
welcomed quote pro-life legislation
there is very little that is pro-life
about this bill
if a ban passes write David Chen and
Patricia mizay for the New York Times if
a ban passes and is signed into law by
DeSantis Florida would prohibit abortion
before many women even realize they are
pregnant
the bills had been telegraphed for weeks
Republican leaders who controlled
Tallahassee sought to build on the
anti-abortion momentum generated by the
U.S Supreme Court's overturning of Roe v
Wade DeSantis expected to run for
president said he supports additional
restrictions but the bills offer a
reminder of the political complexities
that he must navigate abortion
restrictions appeal to Republicans but
64 percent of Florida residents believe
abortion should be legal in most or all
cases now that's actually you know this
is a bigger Trend with abortion in
general
which is that if you go back to the
start of the Roe v Wade era you find
that today
rather than a month ago rather than a
year ago today support for abortion
being legal in most cases is higher than
it has been at any time during that Roe
v Wade era and so although the
anti-abortion stuff is useful for
raising money from certain pieces of the
electorate it's useful for playing red
meat games and throwing red meat out to
supporters in practice when you talk to
Americans although there are still many
Americans of course tens of millions who
are just against any abortion at any
time period for the most part Americans
believe abortion should be legal in most
cases and so there is a political
complexity but let's talk about the
six-week thing
um this is the the critical aspect to
this as a de facto way to just ban
abortion completely why well pregnant
women are considered to be four weeks
pregnant by the time they miss their
period often that's the first sign of
pregnancy now another thing that's
important to remember is how closely any
particular woman would be tracking this
does depend on whether she's trying to
be pregnant or not and we'll we'll sort
of get to that but the first day of your
last period is technically day one of
the pregnancy if you have a 28-day cycle
which is sort of like the average so
you're already four weeks pregnant at
the point at which you suspect you might
be missing your period if you're not
actively trying to conceive
you may not realize you're pregnant
within the two weeks that are left after
the missed period and missed periods
can mean nothing right there could be a
plus or minus seven days or something
like that so now you're at five weeks
but the limit is six weeks I know people
who did IVF in vitro fertilization they
were tracking they were monitoring
everything they didn't know they were
pregnant until what would have been five
weeks into the pregnancy most obese
won't even see a patient for a new
pregnancy until the eight week Mark
unless you're having fertility issues
and they say come in we're gonna do
um an HCG I believe it is blood test to
figure out what's going on and check the
level so by this point you are you would
no longer legally be able to get an
abortion in the State of Florida that's
the point and so normal people would say
oh that makes it really difficult to get
an abortion at all that doesn't make
sense the people who want the bill are
saying oh that'll make it really
difficult to get an abortion at all
that's exactly what we want without
outright Banning abortion so this is
something that Florida Republicans are
pushing we're going to continue seeing
this in other states some states have
really old laws that were that are still
in place
but that weren't uh relevant because of
Roe v Wade's existence with the removal
of Roe v Wade now those laws are once
again being
revived and evaluated from a state a
supreme court standpoint in some states
so this is all going to get worse and
worse and worse now quite frankly I
don't think
Republicans at the federal level are
really going to be running on this
because they know the numbers and in
fact
I I may be wrong but in in this nascent
stage of his candidacy I don't think
I've heard Trump talk about abortion
almost ever uh and much of the focus
when it comes to the Social and cultural
issues has been on transgender issues
and we've been talking about that and
covering it so we'll see where this goes
in Florida
we'll zoom out and in a year we will see
where the abortion landscape is but it
is absolutely scary and horrifying stuff
I want to stick with Florida for a
moment because Florida Republican
governor recently widely re-elected Ron
DeSantis who is considered the best
Challenger to Donald Trump's 2024
Republican Presidential candidacy even
though he has not announced at this
point that he is running
DeSantis or Des Sanctus as he is known
to some now delivered his State of the
State address yesterday his wife showing
up almost as delusionally as him uh
acting like she's you know Jackie
Onassis at a state of the union it all
just bizarre the Optics bizarre but what
was really wild was the content of
desantis's speech as delusional and off
the rails of we as we have seen him
and there's definitely the feeling here
that when he's talking about the second
term as Governor he's really laying out
an agenda for a possible presidential
run let's start to look at a couple of
these clips uh here he is sort of
cheerleading himself I guess we would
say November's election results
represent a Vindication of our joint
efforts over these past four years the
results also vest in us the
responsibility to lead and provide us
the opportunity to shoot for the stars
right boldness be our friend in this
endeavor we have a lot we need to
accomplish really electric and inspiring
as you can tell our two billion dollar
tax cut package is the largest tax cut
package in Florida history although many
who need relief from inflation
especially our Florida families by
permanently eliminating sales tax on all
baby supplies diapers wipes clothes crib
strollers we will be able to say that in
Florida having a child will be tax-free
we are proud to be pro-family and it
damn wetter whether it damn better well
be because if that new anti-abortion
bill passes six-week abortion ban you're
essentially going to be forced to have
those babies so it so so he's making it
really affordable for when you are
forced to have a baby in the State of
Florida and we are proud to be pro-life
in the State of Florida the Charisma as
you can see the electricity just
dripping dumping out of Ron DeSantis and
and again I'm kidding that to me seems
like one of his biggest liabilities in
thinking about a presidential run a
national run against Donald Trump trump
is terrible at many things Trump isn't
good on foreign policy he doesn't
understand economics right their
disaster Trump is good at nicknaming
stigmatizing and making fun of people
and if you have the total lack of
Charisma that Rhonda Santa's has and
seemingly a complete lack of sense of
humor as well I don't know how you run a
national campaign against Trump but we
will get to that later duh at this point
almost a requirement if you were a
republican speaking to your constituents
to throw in something that is
anti-transgender and indeed Ron DeSantis
did it's sad that we have to say this
but our children are not guinea pigs for
science experimentation and we cannot
allow people to make money off
mutilating them Chloe Cole is now a
young adult but she was receiving
puberty blockers at age 13 and she
underwent a double mastectomy at age 16
mastectomy dear God no clue what he's
talking about she's now an advocate
against allowing these procedures for
our children Chloe thank you for your
bravery and the people of Florida and
the legislature should heed your advice
and provide protection and Chloe is
standing uh and and had been sitting
next to Des sanctus's wife against these
procedures
think of it stand and by the way the the
just everything about this the Optics
are completely whacked
um a standing ovation for I guess what
they call detransitioning
there's even a little kid clapping I
presume that that's the sanctus's kid so
listen I mean we know why they're doing
this this stuff gets Applause it gets
the biggest Applause CPAC it gets the
biggest Applause no matter where it is
the we we should be uh diligent we
should be careful we should have a
process for all sorts of gender
affirming care the reality is you look
at 27 studies which were reviewed with 8
000 different transgender individuals
who had the gender affirming surgery
under one percent under one percent less
than one percent Express regret over
their choice to transition so it's not a
big story
um in addition there was a 2022 study in
the Netherlands which found that of 720
different adolescent patients so now
looking specifically at adolescence
doesn't mean an eight-year-old right
they say oh they're chopping off the
breasts of an eight-year-old
eight-year-olds don't have breasts so
that doesn't really make any sense but
study of of Dutch adolescence
um 98 percent
who were given the puberty blockers
properly prescribed
um continue with that and do not express
any regrets so we've we we should
research all of these things as I've
mentioned before there are questions
about puberty blockers and whether all
effects are quote reversible there are
questions about bone density I mean
listen study all of it study all of it
we don't want to let science get in the
way of us knowing we don't want to let
politics get in the way of the science
of us learning everything we can learn
about anything that would be made
available to people but DeSantis is
doing it because he knows that it's a
way to Virtue signal at this point in
time lastly and this is about as as
excited as you'll ever see DeSantis he's
promising Floridians You Ain't Seen
Nothing Yet now's not the time to rest
on our Laurels right we have the
opportunity and indeed the
responsibility whoa to swing for the
fences so that we can ensure Florida
remains number one don't worry about the
chattering class ignore all the bad now
remember Florida is I I love Florida
parts of it but it's not number one in
anything it's not number one in business
infrastructure health education crime I
mean it's just it's a very it's a it's a
fine State it's a mediocre State ranked
between 20 and 30 in just about every
category is keep the compass set to True
North right we will stand strong we will
hold the line we won't back down and I
can promise you this
you ain't seen nothing yet thank you all
got beautifully delivered bless you God
bless you yeah
um just uh so this is a preview of what
a DeSantis presidential campaign would
be like lacking completely just a
complete and total lack of Charisma and
electricity and I quite frankly am very
interested to see how it goes the math
of it the data does not suggest to me
right now that this guy is capable of
defeating Trump in a national and
particularly a protracted national
campaign uh I think it's a good question
for someone like a bill share let's see
if maybe we can get him on soon we're
going to take a very quick break make
sure you're subscribed to the YouTube
channel youtube.com the davidpackman
show make sure if you prefer the show in
Spanish that you have found the Spanish
Channel at davidpackman.com Spanish
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman 15 for 15 off the link is down
below
we are a viewer and listener supported
program grab yourself a membership at
joinpakman.com we do a show every day
after this show is over for our members
so if you like the show and that prompts
you to support the show you get more
show which is an incredible thing sign
up at joinpakman.com and you can use the
coupon code 24 starts now 24 starts now
to get yourself a sizable discount the
Fox News text message leaks have gone
nuclear and the latest tranche reveals
that Tucker Carlson hates Trump
passionately despite acting on his show
like he thinks Trump is a reasonable
person and hanging out with Trump
outside of work and pretending to like
him as well this exposes so many
different layers of the insanity that is
right-wing media the right wing movement
and the Maga movement in the United
States and we're going to look at all of
it but let's start with what we learned
Huffington Post reports Tucker Carlson
exposed says he hates Trump quote
passionately
in private texts the Fox News host said
he deplored the former president in
private and wished for the day he could
ignore him these are text messages from
right before the Trump riots uh text
messages from January 4th 2021 we are
going to look at a number of the
different messages these again have been
revealed in connection with the Dominion
voting systems lawsuit for defamation
against Fox News take a look at this
Tucker texting with an unknown person
we are very very close to being able to
ignore Trump most nights I truly can't
wait
the person that Tucker is texting with
says I want nothing more it does feel
very close very close I imagine things
will get nice starting around
mid-February to which Tucker Carlson
responds I hate him passionately I blew
up at Peter Navarro today in frustration
I actually like Peter but I can't handle
much more of this Tucker hates Trump and
we will get to the
uh uh
hypocrisy and interest of this uh very
very soon
Tucker and Laura Ingram also texting and
it is fascinating Laura Ingram saying to
Tucker Friday numbers aren't that
surprising with Trump impending loss but
how much of the bleed is due to anger at
the news channel this is Laura texting
Tucker about the decline in ratings
right around that time right after the
election in November of 2020. Tucker
says oh a lot meaning a lot of the
ratings decline is because of people
angry that the news side of fox called
the election for Biden and rightly so
Laura says my anger at the news channel
is pronounced and Tucker says it should
be we devote Our Lives to building an
audience and they let Chris Wallace and
Leland effing vidert wreck it too much
Tucker mad
at Chris Wallace because Chris Wallace
actually said some uncontroversial
truths
um and then in a third one here
um Tucker Carlson saying the downside of
the business of the news business is
that a lot of the time you don't get to
choose the news but you're required to
react to it so we actually do earn our
salaries now then uh oh sorry this is
from uh from unknown person they pitch a
podcast to Tucker saying one thought I
had today is a joint venture of sorts
between Tucker Carlson LLC and Fox News
podcasts generally are free and AD
supported we could have a fox backed
podcast promoted on channel Etc that has
one free episode a week and we can
repurpose tuckercarlson.com to host the
podcast and create a Tucker Carlson
podcast app blah blah blah blah blah we
get people to subscribe etc etc and uh
basically pitching a business to Tucker
Carlson while all of this insane
discussion is going on and he's furious
with Trump and he hates him passionately
and on and on and on these are merely
actors and entertainers okay now as a
reminder of course here is Tucker a few
months ago hanging out with Trump at a
golf tournament and Tucker and Marjorie
Taylor green also they look like they're
having a grand old time with Trump so we
this is not a trivial thing to
understand
sometimes people think you know David
it's like there's what you do and
there's The Young Turks and there's Fox
News and there's all this different
stuff it's all the same it is not all
the same Tucker is more like a character
in a movie on his show someone who will
pretend whatever to maintain the show
and the salary that comes with it to
maintain ratings and to maintain access
to power in this case access to power
means being able to hang around Trump
have Trump on whatever the case may be I
believe the things I say I'm not playing
a character on this show and I think
that you will find that this is the case
with just about everybody uh that you
know I would consider a colleague that
is sort of in the field in the business
that I'm in of uh online left-wing
political commentary and Analysis when I
tell you something on the show
I'm not playing a character and
sometimes people in my audience don't
like it for example last week and the
week before I did Clips telling you I'm
not super interested in this Marianne
Williamson candidacy I find her new age
spiritual stuff to be nonsense I don't
think she's going to do anything to push
Biden left I'm not really entertained or
interested or think that the entire
thing is is a super valuable thing it
would be easier for me to do the things
some other shows do which is to say this
is incredibly important Marianne
Williams Williamson is an important
voice and she is a valuable participant
in the Democratic primary and once she
gets on the debate stage with Joe Biden
she's going to show people how valuable
that would be me lying to you and
playing a character and I would get
praise for doing that
if you look online you know Jesse dollar
more has been critical of Marianne
Williamson and he's getting attacked on
Twitter it would be easier for me to
play the character okay but I don't do
that I just tell you what I think and
sometimes there are repercussions and
sometimes people get mad and sometimes
people tune out
Fox News we've now learned Tucker hates
Trump but was still playing up all of
the election lies and he hangs out with
Trump Etc Sean Hannity didn't believe
any of the nonsense he was spouting
Laura Ingram didn't believe the nonsense
she was pounding drowning his own
country to make a buck now will this
affect Tucker's audience in the sense
that now they know the guy I'm a trump
fan and I watch Tucker to get the news
about him now that they know Tucker
actually hates Trump
are they going to tune out or will they
even know that Tucker hates Trump maybe
not let's do one more element of the
Tucker Carlson Revelations from the text
messages and then we'll move on to other
text message revelations in a private
text reports Media Matters Tucker
Carlson called Trump skipping the Biden
inauguration destructive on his show he
didn't mention that and pretended that
coverage of trump skipping the
inauguration was unhinged this is
another way
in which Tucker Carlson was playing a
character wherein the things he said to
his audience were completely different
from the things he said privately Media
Matters reports New Revelations from a
recent court filing in the Dominion
voting system's defamation suit revealed
Tucker Carlson's true opinion about
Trump not going to the Biden
inauguration so destructive and we have
the text messages here
um Tucker is told by an unknown person
maybe you already knew but Gates told me
Trump isn't going to the inauguration
and Tucker says I'd heard that about the
inauguration hard to believe so
destructive that's the right analysis
this tells us this is worse than Tucker
being delusional I believe this is
Tucker having the same opinion I have
and you have which is wow part of the
peaceful transition of power in the
United States is that the outgoing
president goes to the inauguration of
the incoming president totally standard
uncontroversial View
Tucker doesn't actually think it's a
good thing for Trump to skip the
inauguration he shares my view he shares
what I'm sure is your view
but that's not what he said on the air
and if we actually go to the types of
things that Tucker did say on the air
about the inauguration they included
making fun of Jim Acosta for wearing a
mask and not mentioning ever by the way
it's not good that Trump is skipping
this it's bad for the country here's
just one example of Tucker's coverage of
that inauguration of losing their job
Jim acostenci then lost his job you may
not have read that he's no longer going
to be there chief White House
correspondent he's still oppressed
though today Jim Acosta is celebrated
the ouster of a dictator fascist so bad
that Jim Acosta got a book deal out of
criticizing him
those Horrors are behind us now thank
God Jim Acosta is celebrating the
dictator is gone
so he Anderson this is looking like uh
you know a president or a foreign head
of state leaving Washington uh and you
know in a way uh because the president
is uh defying these traditions of not
being a part of the inauguration of
President Joe Biden uh he's almost
leaving town like a uh an autocrat uh
Alice did from Power heading off into
exile
it's just hilarious that someone who is
literally wearing a black mask on
cameras calling someone else a fascist
why are you wearing a mask you're not
going to get coveted outside at a live
shot okay so Tucker's actual belief we
now know was you know what Jim Acosta is
right it is a really bad thing that
Trump isn't going to this inauguration
but what he said instead was why is Jim
Acosta wearing a mask Outdoors
he is playing a character and it's a
disgusting character and it's a
profitable character but privately he
thought Trump should go to the
inauguration and he hates Trump
passionately these are the people
that Maga listens to will they keep
listening now that these Revelations
have come out I don't know let me know
depends on whether they even hear about
it I'm not going to spend the entire
show on the Fox News text message
Revelations but there is one more set of
Revelations that I want to talk about
with you
some of these newly revealed texts
expose that Fox News propaganda's Maria
Bartiromo and former Trump
um advisor Stephen Bannon
are True Believers okay with Tucker
Carlson we learned he was pretending he
hates Trump doesn't like him at all
thinks he's a hates him
passionately looked forward to when he
could stop talking about Trump Maria
Bartiromo and Steve Bannon seem to be
actual True Believers this is completely
insane
Steve Bannon and Maria Bartiromo uh
reports Media Matters plotted to
discredit Biden and get barter Romo
elected to the Senate Bannon texted 71
million voters will never accept Biden
this process is to destroy his
presidency before it starts if it even
starts
um
this is so insane okay let's look at a
couple of the text messages Maria text
Steve Bannon oh my God I'm so depressed
I can't take this can you join me
Thursday sorry about the delay
Bannon writes back yes we've got this
Maria Bartiromo says I am watching the
world move forward and it's so upsetting
Steve Maria is upset that the world is
moving forward with Joe Biden as the
president why well because Joe Biden won
Maria adds I want to see massive fraud
exposed will he be able to turn this
around I told my team we are not allowed
to say president-elect at all not in
scripts or in banners on air until this
moves through the courts
um Bannon then responded as Media
Matters writes uh 71 million voters will
never accept Biden this process is to
destroy his presidency before it starts
if it even starts and Bartiromo replied
but I'm scared and sad
and Bannon says you are our fighter
enough with the sad we need you we need
we want you to run against Schumer this
is your moment Bannon then texted barter
Roma what he called the plan listen to
this number one we either close on
Trump's Victory or delegitimize Biden
two win both seats in Georgia that
didn't happen three win back the house
in 2022 okay that did happen four elect
you to the Senate five if we don't close
on Trump Victory now have Trump declare
for 2024 the day after taking back the
house and your win in November of 2022.
now of course Maria Bartiromo did not
end up running for Senate
Trump did end up announcing that he was
running but instead of right after the
2022 midterms it was right before the
2022 midterms they seem to be true
believers now I want to add one caveat
here
Steve Bannon may be pretending for the
benefit of Maria Bartiromo okay Steve
Bannon is Devious and smart enough that
even these text messages to me leave
open the possibility that Bannon doesn't
believe any of this crap but he
recognizes that Maria Bartiromo does and
so he's playing it up to her
I don't know but there are definitely
some True Believers out there my
question to you what's worse the true
believers who are completely
disconnected from reality like Maria
Bartiromo or
the people that are just lying like
Tucker Carlson who knows Trump didn't
win
who doesn't like Trump who hates Trump
passionately but they go on air and they
pretend reality is different which is
worse let me know what you think leave
it in a comment and you can find all of
these clips and text messages on our
Instagram by searching Instagram for
David packman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
I can't believe this is happening we've
We've joked about this we were kidding
it was just a joke a new report finds
that Donald Trump is considering Carrie
Lake to be his vice president in his
2024 presidential campaign
um I I don't know where to start axios
reports scoop Kerry Lake among Four
Women Trump is considering for VP pick
former president Trump is strongly
considering picking a female running
mate and sees Carrie Lake as a model for
his vice presidential pick according to
people who have discussed it with him
um Lake of course is the former TV
anchor she lost her race for governor in
November
Trump believes one of his weaknesses is
white Suburban women that he's going to
need white Suburban women to defeat
President Biden and so the thought is
what about Lake now what are her
qualifications well axios I mean this
isn't this isn't satire from axios but
it is a joke in the in the sense that
it's wild that this is what's going on
lake has shown she's willing to defend
Trump vociferously no matter the issue
or controversy that's true she's a true
believing sycophant that's absolutely
true
Trump's friends to the extent he has any
say that Kerry lake has a big downside
he wants no risk that is running running
mate could outshine him and Lake would
be assumed to be angling for president
from the day she enters the White House
she even went to Iowa last month and of
course losing her winnable Governor's
race hurts her Mojo
wow now Trump is considering four women
who else is there there's Nikki Haley
who is running against him and uh Trump
apparently believes she won't take any
votes from him so she's not really a
danger
another idea is Arkansas governor Sarah
Huckabee Sanders who was Trump's White
House Press Secretary
that's uh pretty wild and then fourth is
South Dakota Governor Christie gnome
who's often mentioned by Trump
confidants although I don't know that
she carries the faux gravitas of uh of
of Carey Lake I can't believe this is
real life but it is true and of course
when you step back you say she has an
unblemished record of never winning
anything she's a complete Trump suck-up
she lies uncontrollably and constantly
that seems like it would make her a bad
candidate but that actually is seen as
making her a good candidate now that
being said I think it's important to be
bearing in mind that Trump could win
could win with anyone as VP and Kerry
Lake being that close to the presidency
is truly horrific stuff so there's two
perspectives on this and this is the
same sort of question that came up
during my interview yeah yesterday with
Adam Schiff which is on the one hand you
and I look at Kerry Lake and we say oh
my goodness that's more of a joke than
Sarah Palin it would be terrible for
Trump at the national level we should
hope that he picks someone as crazy as
Carrie Lake
the Counterpoint is
Trump could win
and there is going to be no guarantee if
Trump is the nominee that Trump will be
defeated in November of 2024. do we
really want to risk Kerry Lake becoming
the vice president and then being a
Heartbeat Away from the presidency
because we think it would hurt Trump's
chances or is it simply too much risk
now of course at the end of the day it's
not up to us it's up to Republican
primary voters but what started as a
joke it really was just oh you know
Marjorie Taylor green and Kerry Lake are
angling to be Trump's VP but it's just a
joke that's all it is The Insider scoop
is that Kerry lake is not only being
considered she's only one of four being
considered and quite frankly seems to be
more of a front-runner based on her
level of sycophancy than a bunch of
these other people
truly horrifying stuff but this seems to
be the direction that Trump is going
let's talk just briefly a few more
minutes about Kerry Lake Carrie Lake
came up with a story that no one in my
audience seems to believe and I don't
know that I believe either Kerry Lake
recently came out and said
someone came to my house the other day
and they offered me a ton of money and a
cushy job if I leave politics and just
get out of politics and she says it was
someone known to her now of course as
soon as I heard this story I thought to
myself she's a loser so far why would
anyone pay her to get out of politics
when she just loses
um she went on the Charlie Kirk show
yesterday using this very very intense
camera filter very very soft Focus
filter that she loves and she elaborated
on the story it won't surprise you that
she isn't naming the people or person
that allegedly did this let's take a
listen and see if any of it sounds
believable
here we go you were offered money almost
a bribe from powerful people to leave
politics
tell us about that yeah yeah well you
know I was on your show I don't know a
couple weeks ago and you asked me about
uh a run for Senate rumors were swirling
and I had I told you look uh you know
dozens of people at this point but
thousands of people have reached out
saying you've got to run for Senate if
if things don't work in the courts
you've got to run for Senate and I said
look my priority is this the governor's
office the race that we won and our case
but if things don't go right well then
I'm not going to get out of politics
because I'm not going to let the same
people who stole this election take our
movement away and silence us so I would
consider that I told you that on your
show and that made some headlines and
that worried a lot of people and on
Tuesday of last week as I was kind of
getting myself ready to go to CPAC I had
a a visitor at my door uh and somebody I
know invited the person in and uh they
started with an offer for a a fancy job
title a nice salary a position on a
board if I would just agreed to not run
for Senate to not be on the ballot to
just stay out of politics kind of park
it for two years to which I laughed I
said are you kidding me uh I think you
do know that I walked away from a
prestigious job and a big paycheck I'm
not motivated by that and conversation
went on and as I finally moved this
person kind of out of my house and said
I've got things to do no thank you it
moved into well what what do you want to
make this happen we want you out there's
some powerful people back East who
really want you out back East they they
know that I will win in a primary and
I'll frankly win in the general election
as well now a lot of the story I mean
listen there's a lot here that doesn't
make any sense first of all why would
someone who lost be seen as such a
threat that they need to pay her to get
out well you could make the argument the
strongest argument would be that
Republicans so she says this is someone
known to her she doesn't say whether
it's a left Winger or a right wing or
you could argue Republicans want her out
because they wrongly think she will hurt
them and of course she's like no I don't
hurt people I mean I won and I won the
governor's race even though they they
stole it and I would win the senate race
if I do that so Republicans are just
wrong for wanting me out the other
argument would be Republicans want me
out because they are rhinos they they I
they don't want my type of Republic
because Republican to run they want
someone who is you know like a Mitt
Romney Paul Ryan or whatever
Democrats would want her out because
they see her as such a threat to them
you know we Democrats need to pay Carey
Lake to get her out of the race because
she would defeat whoever is the eventual
Democratic nominee none of it seems very
plausible I have to tell you pretty
concerned they want to put out their
typical candidates and so the the
conversation turned to what what would
it be what would your price be what's
your price well my price is I want our
elections to be run smoothly and I want
to be in the governor's office now of
course this is idiotic not only because
it's really hard to believe but the
truth is you know that deep down Carey
Lake although she wants to pretend you
can't buy her out if the money was right
of course she would do it right I mean
it's like listen Carrie you lost
you can run for Senate you can run
around and do the campaign and the
entire thing you might lose again or
here's some meaningful amount of money
for you if the money was right she would
of course accept it so it's possible the
story is completely made up it's
possible that it wasn't enough money or
it's possible that really what Kerry
Lake wants is to be Trump's VP we know
that on some level that's something she
wants to do but the story as she is
telling it has so many holes in it it's
like a Swiss cheese where I belong and I
said there is no price there's no price
that you could pay which is of course a
lie to make me go away or the people of
Arizona go away we're going to continue
to fight so I wouldn't take a hundred I
wouldn't take a million I wouldn't take
10 million I wouldn't take 100 million
she would take 10 million that's how
important this fight is that we're in
right now Charlie yeah so listen I I'm
curious whether people in my audience
believe this story obviously she's uh
you know the the weird thing about not
saying who it was is if you're truly
disgusted with someone making this offer
why wouldn't you name them in other
words why are you trying to protect
someone that you see as a deplorable
person making you a disgusting offer
that you would never accept why wouldn't
you expose that they offered this to you
the second part of it is these stories
do have an air of the Trump serve
routines you know they came to me they
said sir and like the stories are very
often made up or at least
extraordinarily distorted three as I as
I'm saying it doesn't seem plausible
based on the facts and then the other
part of it is the emphasis on a run for
Senate from Kerry Lake
she seems to be continuing to say I'm
eventually going to be the governor
because they're going to reinstate me or
end State me I guess it would be so then
why would she be talking about the
Senate anyway as the focus from these
other people if she's really going to be
reinstated like I know you're saying but
David she's not going to be in stated
Governor I know that but if we're
supposed to believe she believes it then
why is she even talking about running
for the Senate she'd be too busy being
Governor it's all insane and my question
to you is do you believe this story do
you think this happened or any version
of this happened or is it being invented
and contrived completely from the ground
up by Carrie Lake let me know in the
comments email in send a tweet however
you want to get in touch uh curious to
see what folks in the audience think
you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show okay I
mentioned we would talk about this we
haven't had time this week we have time
today and I'm not going to spend a ton
of time on it but the CPAC straw poll uh
every CPAC which is sometimes more
frequently than uh we might assume
um at every CPAC there's something
called a straw poll a strop hole is a
vote of those at CPAC who do we want to
see be the Republican nominee or Vice
Presidential nominee now on the bonus
show we already talked about how Kerry
Lake came easily in first place in terms
of who the CPAC attendees wanted to have
as the Vice Presidential nominee the
other bit of this is that
um in the regular straw poll Donald
Trump easily won very very easily won
and in fact DeSantis lost by 42 points
uh there is an article from the hill
Trump easily wins CPAC poll former
president Trump easily won the straw
poll Trump won with 62 percent Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis likely his closest
rival came in at 20
62-20 that's plus 42 for Trump
businessman Perry Johnson who announced
his candidacy this week got five percent
I have to be honest I don't even know
who that is I didn't even know about
that I have no clue what the deal is uh
with Perry Johnson Trump won last year's
straw poll in CPAC with 59 and DeSantis
28. so last year Trump was plus 31 over
DeSantis and now Trump is plus 42. now a
few important things to talk about first
and foremost do CPAC straw polls reflect
Republican primary voters not really
in the sense that there's a lot of
people like listen if you're a Mitt
Romney Republican
in Utah or maybe Massachusetts where
Romney was previously governor and you
kind of want lower taxes and less
business regulation but you're sort of
like pretty reasonable when it comes to
social issues you're not going to CPAC
at all so your vote you're not even part
of this entire thing and when we look at
actual polling what we find is that it's
definitely closer a new morning consult
poll that includes a whole bunch of
different candidates has Trump plus 25
still a very big lead but it is not 42.
um there is a uh uh Emerson College poll
which does have Trump plus 41 but other
than that it's much smaller leads
everything from Trump plus eight all the
way down to actually DeSantis even being
ahead in some polling so is Trump
winning the Republican primary right now
absolutely there's no there's no doubt I
don't think there is any if you look at
the only way you can make the case that
Trump isn't winning is by saying we are
only going to pay attention to like the
Susquehanna poll and that's not a good
methodology we're either looking at an
average of polls or we're looking at all
a rated pollsters or whatever but to
just say based on this one poll that's a
mediocre poll Trump is not winning
doesn't seem accurate so Trump is
absolutely winning right now can it
change sure the other aspect to the
primary uh to the rather CPAC poll that
I think is very very interesting is that
Republican candidate Vivek ramaswamy who
is getting very little support he said
to Stuart Varney on Fox Business that
you can just pay to rig the CPAC straw
poll very interesting claim take a
listen to this is this trumped GOP
I think that the America First agenda
the people who are behind America First
are really committed to putting America
First not Trump first not Vivek first
it's America First and what I saw there
I mean I gave a speech we got five
standing ovations in the middle of the
speech there's a little funny little
secret I learned a steward well you're
not going to get five standing ovations
at the end you you would only get one at
the end so it makes sense they were in
the middle I'm new to this as an
outsider one of the things you see as an
outsider is how corrupt this system is
you know something funny about this I've
attended CPAC before I didn't know it
works this way a consultant calls my
campaign shortly after I declare and
says hey we can get you up to number two
on there if you pay a few hundred
thousand dollars really I was shocked
you know and I mean you know what
there's a lot of people who are making
money oh not only off of me but off of
every presidential campaign this will
probably be not only the most expensive
presidential campaign the one that
people in the industry it's politics and
Industry people make so much money off
of this that one of the things I'm going
to be doing throughout this campaign is
exposing it because you know what I
didn't get to where I am by actually
just getting exploited and I think the
American people actually deserve to see
the sausage getting made did you pay so
absolutely not I mean that is fake so
why would if he paid he got ripped off
he got like zero or something they get
bumped up one over two no I said I would
take my speaking I said I would take my
speaking slot instead and actually you
can people can see that speech on my
website
vivek2024.com see the speech and see the
crowd's reaction and I think people
should be the judge of what's really
going on now earlier we talked about the
Kerry Lake story Kerry Lake says someone
came to her house and said ma'am I'll
give you a bunch of money and a job to
get out of politics I tend not to
believe that that happened do I believe
what Vivek ramaswamy uh uh is claiming
actually took place that he was offered
the opportunity to pay to get himself
the second slot
I kind of do
um I at least am open to it why because
there is already a sort of pay-to-play
Scandal involving the American
conservative Union which is um the
organizer of CPAC involving a guy named
Brian Kelsey this guy Matt schlab who
runs the uh runs CPAC is is a shady guy
to say the least so I am much if you say
to me David do you think that Carrie
Lake's story is the most likely story to
be true or Vivek ramaswami's story is
the most likely to be true true I think
the Rama Swami story is much much much
more likely to be true where will the
polling be in three months in six months
absolutely no idea we're going to follow
it we're going to watch it there is a
new report
that Donald Trump is spending uh days
workshopping nicknames for Ron DeSantis
now I have to tell you this is not a
story about oh it's another Trump rumor
this is genuinely a smart thing to do
this with where the Republican party is
coming up with the best possible
nickname with which to brand and
stigmatize Ron DeSantis
is a good use of time for Trump a lot of
the things Trump spends time on are
completely useless but this makes sense
there's an article in the hill Trump
spends days workshopping nicknames for
DeSantis former president Trump has made
developing nicknames for his Republican
rival and potential presidential
opponent Ron DeSantis a priority as his
team works on his 2024 campaign
according to a new Bloomberg report
Trump has floated Ron dishonest Ron The
Establishment and Tiny d as monikers for
the Florida governor but appears to
favor Ron de sanctimonius Trump coined
Des sanctimonious ahead of the midterm
elections and shortly before launching
his own presidential bid so let's talk
about this
um Trump is terrible at a ton of things
as I said earlier
he is good at making fun of people
that's the reality he's good at
nicknaming people he's good at
stigmatizing people and when you are
potentially going to be fighting someone
as uncharismatic and seemingly unable to
handle your style of attack as Ron
DeSantis one of the best things you can
do is nickname him with something that
will really titillate and scintillate
and hope that he is unable to respond in
kind now the problem with
desanctimonious is I don't think a lot
of Republican voters necessarily know
what it means
and of course it is actually accurate
which is when your sanctimonious you
make a show out of being or appearing
morally Superior to others
Ron DeSantis does do that you need only
look at his State of the State address
from yesterday that he gave in Florida
uh to confirm that but I don't know that
a lot of Republican voters necessarily
know what sanctimonious means so tiny D
is pretty interesting and there's also
this uh high heels story I don't know
this is so insane that this is where the
Republican party is but Ron DeSantis for
a while has been wearing it's it's I
it's it's I laugh because it's crazy
that this is where we are in American
politics DeSantis has been wearing
high-heeled cowboy boots for a while but
now there is a new suspicion that he's
also wearing lifts inside the boot which
by the way Trump is also suspected of
wearing don't think the sanctimonious is
the only guy doing this so uh Ron
DeSantis officially is only five nine
um but there are images of him looking
as tall as people who are known to be
over six feet tall so of course the idea
would be DeSantis puts a lift inside the
the boot and then wears a high heel and
then he looks 6-1 and people think he's
taller than he actually is all of this
stuff really matters
tall candidates tend to do better now do
they tend to do better because they're
tall well that's a different question uh
we'd have to look at that in a different
way but it wouldn't surprise me if Trump
focused in on some kind of nickname that
related to DeSantis actually being short
ER I mean listen I'm five nine also five
seven five five nine five nine at least
that's what my license says let's put it
that way
um and then you know sort of being
desperate to be six feet tall and
wearing high heels and cowboy boots I
don't know where it's going but it
wouldn't surprise me that it goes in
that uh in in that direction again I
believe that DeSantis is 100 worse than
Trump Adam Schiff had a different
feeling yesterday which was that Trump
really is the danger I think Trump's
incompetence actually makes him less
dangerous and that he's less able to
accomplish things DeSantis is completely
uncharismatic completely uninspiring as
a speaker but he would uh pose a real
threat of getting some really dangerous
stuff done so if I had to pick
I actually do think
the Democratic candidate is better off
facing Trump
and the risk of a trump presidency is
lower than that of a DeSantis presidency
continuing to take opinions from you in
the audience about that question we have
a voicemail number that if you have a
message for me you can call that number
is 219 to David P here is an interesting
voicemail from a republican who says
they are they are a republican I didn't
convert them out of being Republicans
but they have changed their mind about
at least some issues and they like the
show interesting message from a
Republican hey how you doing David uh
this is John from Massachusetts uh I
just want to say uh I'm actually a
registered Republican but I I do enjoy
your show uh you're definitely
I actually started listening to it uh
driving home from work beautiful you
know I was like wow this guy's you know
talking out of his ass I mean probably
my language that's the reaction from
even people that like the show so no no
concerns there sir you know honestly you
definitely grew on me and you definitely
changed my mind about something there
you go uh and I'd be curious what things
those are by the way I really do enjoy
uh when you're making fun of Donald
Trump
that's very funny just gotta say you
should keep that up you're doing pretty
good you I probably I should come on
yourself as a guest soul and
impersonating
you know what I'm saying it would just
be so great so thank you so much David
and have a wonderful day all right the
Trump impression is so so I don't know
that that's the uh best moment of the
voicemail but listen we have a ton of
right Wingers in the audience who I
never hear from who don't insult me who
don't say anti-semitic things who uh
don't make threats who just listen to
get a different opinion and sometimes we
find points of agreement and that's a
really great thing uh I welcome that I
think that that's fantastic if I'm only
speaking to left Wingers
what the hell am I doing at the end of
the day so A beautiful voicemail great
to hear from you we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today Oklahoma voters
have rejected legalizing recreational
Cannabis what is this the first such
failure we will discuss the White House
has endorsed a new Senate Tick Tock Bill
and is urging Congress to pass it
quickly does that make sense should
Tick-Tock be banned or should it be
regulated or should it be controlled or
whatever the case may be we will discuss
and lastly New York city mayor Eric
Adams is now telling stores to have
customers remove their masks when they
come in in order to try to cut down on
shoplifting and thefts and burglary and
robbery or whatever the term is that is
appropriate uh stick ups I guess is what
we're calling them I don't know you all
understand what I'm saying remove the
mask Eric Adam says so that they would
be identified on your security cameras
and maybe be less likely to do it
interesting all of those stories and
more when I am joined by producer pat on
the bonus show you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now to get yourself a
discount and save big off of the cost of
a membership I welcome you all to the
bonus show if you are not a member we
will be back with a new show tomorrow
but why wait we can be together again in
just a few minutes on the bonus trip
foreign